okay now being a little bit mean to you
because it's actually comes from an exam
and the exam comes with a clue right
actually this adapter is full puzzle and
Dom I've taken up the first publishes
the clue because it kind of I don't know
when you as soon as you see a clue
it's like when you get to the end of
like you read back so I want you first
to just and I will I will show you what
a technique it what the property is
we're gonna take it mother I just want
you to push on this for a moment
she says mathematicians right just look
at the first part of the proof upon
which the rest pays these two things
apparently our emails okay but the
question is these have to do with each
other because it looks to on first ones
that they should be different it looks
like they should be different for
instance if I gave you any other
integral and just say okay well I'm
gonna swap out this X right that's the
only different to you with a pi minus X
you would expect that those two
functions are kind of different
you're right so how can it be that these
are the same here's the property that um
I'm going to show you now I'm going to
call it I've got some names of overlap
you but I think it makes sense we hand
the reverse property which is doing the
general backwards we also this symmetry
properties we map on an even close to
this okay this is it man either this but
it's quite closely related to them so
I'm calling this swollen the reflective
problem again this is an information but
hopefully once you see it you're like
okay this name just there make sense if
you are integrating again any function
you like doesn't have to have any
special symmetry or anything like that
if you're integrated from north to ace
if you so choose if it ends up being
useful to you
in this case it was extraordinarily you
can integrate live on the same interval
but you can reflect it about a certain
axis now it doesn't look obvious at the
moment that that's exactly what we do we
but let's do a picture for ourselves
okay
last time last time we did an
exponential form let's borrow just keep
it calm so I find you - great you said
that if I do it this exponential
function from the other hand let's just
call that area that definite integral is
equivalent to this one whatever it is
okay now this point it will become clear
for us to actually put a boundary here
right what difference is there between
these two things which is supposed just
suppose this was my question
okay so now I wanna ask the question
what happens if I have not to the end
but to the a minus X what difference is
there to this show
now to help us make sure we're doing
this right okay I'm actually going to
rewrite this because to two
transformations are happening right
firstly this is a reflection and
secondly there is a translation a shift
okay so to make it a little clearer
what's going on I'm going to make X the
subject inside there right so firstly
there's a negative applied to the whole
thing and what she says is a negative
this is actually not a plus a is it this
is actually a minus name do you see that
okay so I've been reflected vertical
horizontal horizontally okay because it
doesn't adjusting the ends right right
and in addition to that I have a shift
of a units chuga right
yeah like is X minus a and then this X
minus sorry this x squared and six
months a squared which is that right
okay so therefore the shift is going to
look like this well here's here's one
the horizontal thing would do by is the
flip and then I have to go a units to
the right okay so therefore I'm getting
this kind of shape do you see that so I
moved up now do you see what's happened
now when I go on the same interval
control from naught to a what does it
look like
do you see have I have I done it
reasonably enough that this boundary and
this boundary match you see why I've
made it what I named it right is a
reflection happening so visually that's
the way it works
can we do the algebra last time I should
do a substitution that would get us from
the left hand side to the right hand
side do you think you could try to do
can you get a head start at me I might
proof took 1 2 3 4 5 months finally we
have shot at and then we'll have a go at
using it on this question ok so let's
have a look at this now we read from
left to right before I'm going to go
from right to left this time and you can
see a lot of these properties of
different integrals come with an
appropriate they come from an
appropriate substitution just like they
did with why don't we call it the
roundup problem right so one solution
here you can see how that this a - exit
and I don't want to name what is X
I want an X okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna introduce well I just never do
this a - f but it's cool why I chose of
the substitution a - X that'll get rid
of it didn't want it okay if I do that
then two things follow this will change
the integrated for me but I also have to
change that the variable information in
the boundaries
okay so let's do both of those variable
information to do you on the X is going
to be okay so I'm going to pop the
negative on the other side because
there's one so that would change my
variable I'm gonna change my boundaries
- yeah so I'm gonna go by the way I
actually did it in reverse of what I
last time I often like to put my
boundaries actually the positions that
they supposed to be so x equals 0 to x
equals a just so the 1 have to put here
I just don't get confused about the
right so x equals a X equal 0 what am I
gonna get for each one what's my U value
0 and my unit review hey okay so my bad
reason fits around we're just finding
exactly what I want so I'm ready to
enjoy right now when I put this into
place I first changed just in the order
by writing I change my boundaries so
this becomes use A's then this becomes u
equals 0
yep what are we gonna get in here evolve
both you visit the X that was already
there and then here is my change of
variable cancel cancel happy okay I'm
pretty much there on time pretty much
there I've got all of the pieces that I
want this is gonna become f of X DX in a
second by relabeling not by the
substitution but by changing the
variable this negative at the front from
a to knowledge of f of X DX is just
going to take advantage of the robust
property right this is going either the
order than a dirt one so I'm going to
use that negative and there is the left
hand side that's is it
question okay so let's see I'm done a
couple of things here maybe I shouldn't
have done that so quickly
so I've done two things in this line
number one I'm just taking that negative
which is a constant negative one I've
acted out the front yeah yeah that's all
I've done and then I noticed that what I
have left is the integral of f of U do
you after I've taken that negative so do
but U is just a dummy though it's just
the temporary label it's going to get
replaced by these numbers in a second so
therefore ever viewed to you is the same
as f of X DX okay so I'm not using this
is a substitution there's no case at all
okay right what I'm doing is I'm just
relabeling the variable cuz it's just a
dummy it's just sitting there for a
second
until I integrate it does but I'm not
taking I'm what I'm forgetting about
that like I could have relabeled this
line could have said after four theta to
theta
Oh F of T DT right I'm using the dummy
variable property not this substitution
I introduced before because if I did
that I'm just going to send myself back
to where I started but I don't want to
do that
I wouldn't go somewhere else yeah yeah
it's just a label I could have I could
have had this line could have been
negative a from 0 of F of Nikita is
still okay it's just the label that's
just me